il est souhaitable que vous vous
décidiez dès maintenant sur le choix de
votre nom le choix de mon nom le oui
madame votre nom de règne celui que vous
déciderez de porter en tant que reine
dans ce cas nous n'allons pas compliquer
inutilement les sources mon prénom et
elisabeth
soit l'on vit à la reine elizabeth
vous vous sentez salle en effet c'est
pourquoi il est important d'avoir la
bonne personne à ses côtés vous
comprenez que les titres de noblesse ce
n'est pas le travail
c'est elle le travail et mais là
protéger là c'est elle qui est l'essence
de votre devoir
nous avons un nouveau souverain une
femme une jeune femme
je vais descendre de l'avion avec elle
non monsieur si vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient
la couronne a la préséance vous ne
pensez pas que j'aurais préféré grandir
loin des projecteurs
loin de la cour loin du regard de tous
soyez ferme
appuyez-vous uniquement sur la loi jo
c'est que ce binz thème sur tille mais
n'oubliez pas qui vous êtes vous allé
resalah reine d'angleterre
cette nouvelle période élisabéthaine
arrive un moment où l'humanité se tient
dans un équilibre précaire au bord de la
catastrophe
etes-vous mon épouse où êtes-vous
marraine je suis les deux est un homme
fort serait capable de s'agenouiller
devant le jeu vous dit de mon épouse
étant de votre épouse ne vous le demande
pas et marraines me leur donne je vous
demande de faire une exception près non
quelle sorte de mariage est des nôtres
quelle sorte de famille le montre je
dois parler à ma soeur maintenant
je suis bien consciente d'être entouré
par des gens qui pensent pouvoir faire
un meilleur travail sûrement très fort
avec une force de caractère
mais pour le meilleur et pour le pire la
couronne est posé sur ma tête
j'ai vu trois grandes monarchies mise à
bas parce que selon qui les dirigeaient
n'avait pas su séparer leurs exigences
personnelles et devoirs de leur charge
vous devez vous interdire de commettre
des erreurs similaires
la couronne doit gagner doit toujours
gagner